okay so i tweeted about this yesterday
and got some really interesting
responses so i decided to talk about it
today
i've been self-censoring uh on the
program
or censoring myself as some would say
over the issue of recent anti-semitic
attacks
all over the world all over the country
and all over the world
my instinct is never to do this if
there's a story that
i want to cover i cover the story but i
will be very honest with you
the degree of anti-semitism that we've
received across all platforms over the
last two weeks
just for my coverage of the
israeli-palestinian conflict without
actually talking about anti-semitism
really
has been insane we have had to ban
hundreds and hundreds of people
across our platforms from everything
from calling me
a jew rat to people saying blow up all
jews
blow up israel which i consider to be
just as unproductive
as those people who claim that the
pro-israeli side wants to blow up all
palestinians like it's
it it's just as disgusting and
i did something that i don't feel great
about
which is i didn't do a story that i
wanted to do since
last week i wanted to do a story about
how
criticism of the israeli government and
foreign policy
which is valid and in which i
participate myself and have for a long
time
that has become cover for fuel for
an opening for just out and out
anti-semitism and even physical violence
against random jewish people or people
believed to be jewish out on the streets
normally i'd be telling you but i
haven't about all of these different
things and yesterday i tweeted
if i'm completely honest i hesitate to
do a segment covering the anti-semitic
attacks and beatings of the last week
because i don't have the stomach for the
deluge of anti-semitism
that such a segment would trigger
against me
even the responses to that tweet
were filled with anti-semitic comments
which immediately led to me just
blocking a whole bunch of people and i'm
not going to highlight any of those
messages today
but i've decided to talk about this
today partially because of some of the
positive responses i received
and also because it's already not being
talked about enough
as i see coverage of
this issue the the anti-semitic attacks
are already not getting enough coverage
and if i don't talk about it i'm helping
for it to be erased and i can't do that
now for some reason there are some on
the left
who do not talk about anti-semitism
either because they
believe it conflicts with their views
about israeli foreign policy
which is a different topic israeli
foreign policy and anti-semitism
are two different topics unless you only
talk about the former
to hide the latter but that's a very
specific case
uh some on the left don't talk about
anti-semitism because they see
jewish americans as an elite privileged
group
which in and of itself is actually based
on an anti-semitic trope
so i know that this is going to be a
mess i know we'll have to block another
few hundred people
but we have to talk about what's been
going on for example three men went to a
synagogue in new york city
made anti-semitic comments to just four
dudes hanging out outside and vandalized
the synagogue
a synagogue in chicago has been
vandalized
thursday night a random jewish man in
new york city's times square was beaten
up just in the middle of the street a
beating
29 year old with a yarmulke in new york
city assaulted by a violent mob
called a filthy jew a dirty jew
saying hamas will kill all of you and
israel will burn
guys that's not a criticism of israeli
foreign policy that's
anti-semitism in los angeles a group of
people went to a sushi restaurant
and shouted anti-israeli comments at
people they believed to be jews
while brandishing a deadly weapon in bal
halber
bal harbour florida eric organ said he
was walking with his family
with uh with his fa while vacationing
when four men in an suv began yelling
anti-semitic comments organ was wearing
a yarmulke
the men shouted free palestine and die
jew as well as threats to rape his wife
and daughter
they threw garbage at the family feces
has been
left outside of a synagogue another man
torched
a jewish community center synagogues in
some places
are now hiring armed security i could go
on but it's not necessary
because the big picture is that
officials say hate crimes against jews
are growing dramatically in the
aftermath of the recent
israeli-palestinian flare-up and
violence
we are witnessing a dangerous and
drastic surge in anti-jewish
hate said the head of the
anti-defamation league the
anti-defamation league has identified
193 reports of anti-jewish incidents in
the last week
135 reports the week before
and the point here is and i really wish
that some of the anti-israeli people
understood this
when israel does something and jews
around the world
many of whom have never been to israel
most of whom have never been to israel
are attacked on the streets it makes
more and more people say wow
i might have to move to israel someday i
hope people understand this
if you really want to help make progress
on the israeli-palestinian conflict and
get more people on your side
like me fighting for a safe and fair
situation for israelis and palestinians
lifting the blockade stopping the
settlements getting leaders on both
sides that actually care about
the people in a real way right don't do
stuff that makes jewish people say holy
it's insane out there i might need to
move to israel to feel safe
this is the great conundrum the more of
this stuff that goes on
the more people will say i don't care
what israel does
because i might need to flee there
someday and we saw this in europe as
anti-semitism exploded under trump
due not because of trump but during the
trump era we saw the far-right
nationalist movements in europe
and anti-semitism the desire to move to
israel
for safety went up so the best thing
that these people can do
if they can put their anti-semitism on
hold for a second
is don't make random jews around the
world feel unsafe
don't make jews on the streets of new
york city
feel so unsafe that they say i might
have to move to israel
to be safe okay so it's an incredible
conundrum
and so counterproductive and obviously
toxic and disgusting so
listen i know what a lot of the reaction
will be to me doing this segment
uh but i can't not say anything about it
um let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter
at d pacman